well the the trouble with Boris Johnson
is that we have heard him deny things in
the past which has subsequently turned
out to be true I I can't remember the
invert what was it his line was an
inverted pyramid
yes I can't remember what what that was
but anyway it proved to be completely
and utterly true and not an inverted
pyramid of people at all so
um and and it is true that sometimes
Boris Johnson finds himself innocent in
the court of his own opinion but
um and you're right I'm very hesitant to
get into the specifics of this case
because
um a there's potentially a police
investigation B there's the Privileges
inquiry which I'm not party to I recuse
myself
um from sharing that because I believe
that I I already had a view as to
whether Boris Johnson has misled
Parliament and done so recklessly or
deliberately and that might be Mr Bryant
uh well yes it's very publicly known I I
think he did it seems to me self-evident
that if you turned up to events
um at which uh which was subsequent for
which we were subsequently fined you
probably knew that there were events
going on in Parliament that didn't meet
the legal requirements
um and that you weren't abiding by your
own lockdown rules and there were
parties in Parliament and therefore what
you had told Parliament was not true and
if you then chose not to correct the
record in time or at all ever in fact up
until this day then probably you have
not only
um accidentally or inadvertently misled
Parliament you've probably deliberately
done so or certainly
um allowed the misleading of parliament
to stand and that is a culpable contempt
of parliament in my view but I'm not on
the committee so that's almost
completely and utterly irrelevant what
the thing that worries me most at the
moment if if I might forever is
um so we've got the covert inquiry we've
got the police investigation we've got
the in the the inquiry by this
privileges committee we've also in the
last week um had the ministerial code
um uh a decision on the ministerial code
in relation to swallow Braverman I think
that was an odd decision but be that as
it may that's yet another body that's
been doing an investigation and you also
have
um this week there have been uh stories
in the Press today that MPS have been
claiming or some MPS have been claiming
and speeding or parking fines on their
expenses
um and that is regulated by yet another
body which is ipsa the independent
parliamentary standards Authority
yeah may I just asked you actually I
want you to come to that point about uh
MP's claiming uh the cost of parking
fines on their expenses two things first
of all um are you going to be
investigating that
through your committee number one and
number two from what we know the rules
at the moment is that actually wrong
uh well as I was about to explain
weirdly
um the rules on expenses are governed by
ipsa a separate body and my committee
the standards committee has no power to
investigate
um well in fact we can't investigate
anything it's only the Parliamentary
commission for standards investigates if
he thinks there might have been a breach
of the rules and then reports to us and
then we adjudicate on them
um but ipsa is a stat for your body so
it's laid down in statute law and it has
a um uh an officer who is their solely
to decide whether people have breached
the um the rules and they would then
refer things to the police because it's
the criminal offense to to
um uh false accounting or break or
breaking their laws on
um parliamentary expenses so no we can't
investigate
um uh to my mind it is manifestly wrong
I don't care whether it breaches a rule
it is manifestly wrong for somebody to
you know if you're an ordinary member of
the public you can't go off and uh if
you uh parked uh if you've been caught
parking in the wrong in the wrong place
at the wrong time or not having a
getting a parking ticket or is feeling
fine you can't claim that on your daily
expenses can you so I don't see why this
could be why MP should be any different
sadly sky is not that kind to to us and
um of course we have to say that we we
don't know who those MPS are and they
can't be here to answer for themselves
but um you set out the principle very
clearly
um
there's a general issue I think which is
now building up which is the
relationship between politicians and the
Civil Service
on Tuesday the cabinet office has a
deadline and that's a deadline for uh
sending the unredacted versions of Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages to the
covered inquiry covered inquiries
demanded them
um do you feel confident that the
cabinet office is behaving correctly and
that the inquiry is getting what it
needs from the government
well I I read you know you can't believe
everything you read in newspapers as you
know but
um I I read a newspaper account which
seemed to suggest that the covert
inquiry was having to use
um Powers which incidentally not even my
committee the standards Committee in
Parliament has
um and and the covert inquiry has them
under the um inquiries act to Fourth
government ministers to provide things
um there shouldn't be you would have
thought that
what is the fundamental principle of
good government that openness and
transparency
um is there the ministerial code says in
terms that no Minister shall ever refuse
to provide some information unless it is
um legally necessary to do so and and so
I think there's a danger here that if
the covert inquiry doesn't get
everything it needs in a timely fashion
that it will feel to the British people
as if ministers are trying to obstruct
um a proper inquiry and and that will be
both a break for the ministerial code
and morally offensive there are lots of
people you know I mean my constituents
still want to understand why so many
people died in Care Homes
um and there was no proper ring of
protection put around them and people
were sent to Care Homes so I think
people want to know the truth is all I
was going to say and sorry one month one
month sorry to bang on but one other
thing My worry is that we have so many
different organizations and so many
different rules that is actually very
difficult for the public and for that
matter politicians to understand but
who's it who's who governs who regulates
what particular bit the ministerial code
the civil service code and I think all
of this is right for reform the whole
system is simply not fit for purpose
anymore
okay
Chris Bryant thank you for banging on
with us this this morning no that's what
we're here for thanks very much for your
time